now for people who don't know what what
gay does
it is it's one of the most important
things on on
a show
i mean any any object anything that the
story calls for
this is gay's job to go and find it make
it happen make it beautiful make it
accessible make it cool so whether it's
the right coffee mug or a or a crazy car
or
uh i mean well first of all gay what's
the craziest thing you've that
showed up in a script that you had to go
and find
um
well
right now i'm making a
um
dildo pogo stick
that would do it
and this is for the show this is for the
show called dildo pogo stick right it's
a very specific show it's uh it's on
peacock premium you guys i progressed
after parks and rec and i went to porn
uh
a dildo pogo stick well
that's i mean it's funny and and
my craziest prop story ever
is a similar theme i was on
californication a great showtime show
david duchovny and playing one of my
favorite characters eddie nero that i
ever played
and um there was a fight scene and in
the script it said eddie is excited by
the fight
and i thought what if that was also
sexually
so i went into the bathroom and rolled
up
a a paper towel and taped it and put it
in my pants
and stood up with it in my pants and the
prop person came to me would you just
prefer a dildo and then brought out
a case of beautifully
presented and you just had them right
there so you you have to be prepared for
anything in your job the prop truck has
a lot of stuff on it right
yeah i like to play a game whoever comes
on my trailer and say i'll say say
anything and we'll see if it's on the
truck
yeah
i was always amazed i was always amazed
it's like the old uh the old monty hole
let's make a deal yeah do you have an
egg beater in your purse i do i know no
one else cares about that game except
for me but um
especially when my family comes i'll say
come on say something and they they say
the most obvious things i'm like no just
give me something hard and then it's
ridiculous and then i don't have it